wahrscheinlich verwenden sie das hier
auch zum kochen
aber wissen sie auch dass teflon niemand
erfunden hat sondern das material per
zufall entdeckt wurde
auch unser leben kann durch glückliche
zufälle eine überraschende wendung
nehmen oder hat dann er das schicksal
seine hand im spiel
ob sie per zufall ein zeiten oder nicht
schön sind sie dabei herzlich willkommen
und schön sind auch sie dabei meine
heutigen gäste miriam meckel
sie ist verlegerin des digitalen
magazins elle da und professorin für
kommunikations management an der
universität st gallen und svenja
flaßpöhler philosophien und
chefredaktorin des philosophie magazins
in berlin schön sind sie hier
dankeschön vielen dank ja frau merkel
das beispiel der teflonpfanne habe ich
ihrem buch entnommen wer nicht sucht der
findet am besten erzählen sie die
geschichte der fahne gleich mal selbst
ja die geschichte der pfanne ist
eigentlich beispielhaft für ganz viele
geschichten die wir über erfindungen
kennen und hier liegen ja auch ein paar
sachen über die wir vielleicht noch
sprechen können diese fahne stammt oder
geht eigentlich auf ein amerikaner
zurück einen chemiker namens lang rät
der 1938 nicht gedacht ich erfinde mal
diese fanden sondern der hut herum
experimentiert mit gasen in einem labor
bei der firma die es damals noch so gab
und hat diese gase gelagert auf
kühlaggregaten und wollte damit was
machen dann kam eines tages morgens ins
büro und hat festgestellt die gase
hatten sich verwandelt durch ein prozess
den man polymerisation nennt und da war
sozusagen ein heller stoff draus
geworden und dann hat er es natürlich
gedacht mist jetzt ist mein experiment
hin und meine ganzen ideen sind weg und
dann hätte sich das material genauer
angeguckt hat festgestellt dass das
nicht nur wahnsinnig hitzebeständig war
was da entstanden war sondern dass das
auch irgendwie gar nicht gar keine
haftungseigenschaften hatte das alles
davon sozusagen abperlt und abprallt und
hat dann gedacht das ist interessant und
darauf hatte dann ein patent angemeldet
auf den so entstandenen stoff der
politiker für ihn heißt um das auch
einmal gesagt
so eine panne werde keiner kao wurde und
die amerikaner ist natürlich auch
schlauer die haben dann eine firma
gegründet
die kennt man unter dem namen tv ja also
die mischung aus teflon und aluminium
das ist ja das was sozusagen diese
geräte in der küche ausmacht und rolf
lang hat eigentlich durch einen totalen
zufall den auch er die natur geschaffen
hat als er selber nicht nur dass koch
verhalten von millionen menschen
verändert sondern wirklich auch eine
milliardenindustrie ins leben gerufen um
diese stoffe sind dann bei der atombombe
bei angelschnur und eben natürlich von
allen über haushaltsgeräte
jetzt fragt man sich natürlich sofort
wie kommt eine
kommunikationswissenschaftlerin dazu ein
buch zu schreiben in dem es um zahlen
geht die gegenstände die verbindet ja
alle etwas nämlich das so genannte
prinzip der seriendieb i tät darauf
kommen wir gleich zu sprechen aber ich
würde gerne noch ganz kurz bei dieser
geschichte bleiben nämlich der zufall
also das ist keine erfindung eigentlich
das testen sondern entdeckung gibt es
die geschichten in ihrem persönlichen
leben drauf lars keller wo sie sagen da
hat wirklich dazu frauen eigentlich den
entscheidenden hinweis gegeben
ja ganz bestimmt wir würden jetzt sogar
einige einige situationen einfallen aber
ich glaube dass das entscheidende ist
dass der zufall da steckt natürlich dass
zufallen drin also eine gewisse
passivität nun wenn man so will da fällt
mir etwas zu da passiert irgendetwas
ohne mein zutun das könnte man erst mal
denken aber ich finde auch in dem
beispiel schon wird ja deutlich wie viel
aktivität letzten endes auch in diesem
prozess steckt also dass man das
überhaupt erst mal erkennt dass es seine
potentially tät gibt in einem material
das man damit etwas anderes machen kann
also ich glaube dass das ist für mich
ganz entscheidend diese eigentlich
dieses zusammenspiel von etwas
kontingentes passiert das ist
unverfügbare erstmal wobei man wir
werden ja noch auf den begriff
zurückkommen der seriendieb steht das
hat natürlich schon auch viel damit zu
tun dass man sozusagen ein feld schafft
in dem sich etwas ereignen kann aber
erst mal passiert da irgendetwas aber
ich mache etwas draus und ich glaube das
ist dann ja auch vielleicht für das was
das leben angeht entscheidend dass man
irgendwie was draus machen muss und die
frage ist ja wie erkennt man aus was man
etwas machen kann zum beispiel und in
welche richtung sollte man etwas machen
lassen
zu machen muss und auch sich darüber
verständigen mussten deshalb die haben
ja zu recht gefragt warum beschäftigt
mannschaft ich mich mit fanden natürlich
nicht in erster linie sondern ich
beschäftige mich eigentlich mit der
kommunikation die in dem ganzen prozess
den sie gerade sehr schön beschrieben
haben eine rolle spielt also das
gespräch mit sich selbst noch über die
dinge die da passieren und das gespräch
auch mit anderen über die dinge die
passieren
in diesen gesprächen entdeckt man unter
umständen etwas ohne ist gesucht zu
haben und das ist im grunde bei all
diesen geschichten aus dem buch immer
das dass der rote faden und vielleicht
noch ein beispiel aufzunehmen damit die
leute auch verstehen warum ihre chips
stehen haben das ist beispiel finde ich
auch so schön da es eine köchin die
etwas angebraten hat in heißem öl
nämlich krapfen und nebenher hat sie in
eile noch kartoffeln geschnippelt und
geschält und da ist ein bisschen
kartoffelschalen das heiße öl vielleicht
in den töpfen und reingefallen und da
kam ich glaube ihr bruder und hat das
genommen und reingebissen gesagt das ist
ja lecker was hast du das gemacht und
das war ja eigentlich nur müll wenn man
so will ein abfallprodukt und das war
sozusagen die erfindung des pumps und
ich glaube was was uns vielleicht weiß
nicht wie es ihnen geht aber was mich
daran wirklich so fasziniert an diesem
prinzip und auch an dieser geschichte
jetzt mit den chips ist ja diese
leichtigkeit die da irgendwie drin
steckt es ist sowas ist ja es passiert
man spielt ein bisschen irgendwie auch
etwas mit spiel zu tun und ich glaube
das was einen so daran vielleicht auch
jetzt so in unseren berufen so
fasziniert ist ja dass wir ja beide
irgendwie in kreativberufen stecken also
wir sind irgendwie ständig ja dabei
neues hervorzubringen oder wollen das
gerne und das kriegt ja leicht was
angestrengtes und diese leichtigkeit
dieses spiel dieses das ist das trotzdem
glaube ich so eine schönheit verleiht
kann man eine bahnbrechende erfindung
wenn man sich entscheidet eine
bahnbrechende erfindung zu machen dann
wird ganz viel passieren nur ganz sicher
nicht die bahnbrechende genau die
anstrengen verstehen jedoch mal dieses
prinzip der parität ein bisschen besser
und dieses prinzip spielt ja vor allem
auch in der wissenschaft und in der
innovation eine ganz bedeutende rolle
gott würfelt nicht sagt der albert
einstein die forschung aber tut es oft
ist sie ein glücksspiel bei dem niemand
weiß was genau herauskommt doch im
gegensatz zum casino lohnt es sich in
der wissenschaft immer risiken in kauf
zu nehmen und den zufall herauszufordern
für chemie professoren helma wennemers
gehört der faktor zufall zwingend zu
einer forschung die neuland erkunden
will allerdings seine spezielle art des
zufalls vordringen in unbekanntes gebiet
da weiß man nicht was einen erwartet und
es gibt zufälle
allerdings ist jetzt sofort in der
wissenschaft ein ganz anderer zufall als
der im casino es ist ein zufall der sich
gut mit dem begriff serendipity
beschreiben lässt
im gegensatz zum einfachen zufall wie im
glücksspiel bedeutet serendipity bei der
suche nach etwas zufällig auf etwas
anderes noch weit bedeutenderes zu
stoßen
wohl berühmtestes beispiel an der großen
entdeckung die der zufall generierte ist
die reise von columbus er suchte ganz
gezielt eine neue schied gute nach
indien und entdeckte den amerikanischen
kontinent
das erste und bekannteste antibiotikum
das penizillin ist übrigens auch per
zufall entdeckt worden
der schottische bakteriologe alexander
fleming experimentierte mit bakterien
als er 1928 sommerferien machte ließ er
zufällig das fenster des labors offen
durch dieses wertes pilzsporen herein
welche auf den bakterienkulturen
landeten als fleming aus den ferien
zurück kam hatte sich auf den versuchs
platten schimmel gebildet
zuerst wollte er die proben wegwerfen
doch dann realisierte er dass überall
dort wo sich der schimmelpilz
ausbreitete die bakterien eingingen
penicillin war erfunden und rettete
seither millionen menschen das leben
frau merkel per zufall zum erfolg ja
absolut ganz oft also da gibt es halt
wirklich ganz viele geschichten die
zeigen dass man wenn man sozusagen ich
sag mal geistig vorbereitet ist in einer
art und weise dass man aufgeschlossen
ist und und denkt freiraum hat um den zu
verlanden zu lassen sich etwas zu fallen
zu lassen dass man damit bahnbrechende
entwicklungen in die welt bringen kann
und sein eigenes leben und das leben von
vielen anderen menschen verändern kann
aber es reicht nicht einfach da zu
sitzen und zu warten bis der zufall mehr
zufälligerweise etwas da ich mich auf
den tisch bild was ich nachher brauchen
genau wie schon gesagt man muss man muss
in den experimentierfeld schaffen man
muss ja irgendwie schon mal so ungefähr
vielleicht auch wissen wonach mann mann
mann mann mann sucht irgendetwas und
dann gibt es vielleicht eine abweichung
und entdeckt man vielleicht was anderes
also man muss den zufall
ich glaube das habe ich am anfang ihres
buches steht das mit den türstopper an
vielleicht ist das auch ein ganz schönes
bild also man macht so man wie man man
man man haut so flecker ein irgendwie
und begrenzt erstmal das feld und in
diesem feld kann sich dann etwas
ereignet
aber was ich wirklich jetzt auch noch
mal schön fand an dem was sie gerade
gesagt haben dass offen sein also dass
ich offen sein muss für das neue dass
ich mich eben nicht verkrampft auf das
was ich eigentlich suchen
oder den gedanken den ich jetzt
eigentlich denken will und ich glaube
das kennt man ja dieses grübeln die sich
verschrauben verzweifeln daran sondern
dass man offen ist und auch loslassen
kann und dann plötzlich also das
typische beispiel ist ja so man geht
plötzlich man geht unter die dusche oder
so und dann plötzlich erhält es einem
ein oder zu und diese offenheit dass das
ist glaube ich auch ein ganz
wesentlicher ein ganz wesentliches
ingredients von von von erfindungen oder
von innovation aber sie beide arbeiten
in der medienwelt wahrscheinlich oft
auch unter hohem druck sie beide sind
auch buchautorin beide erfolgreich kann
man sich diese zeit dann immer nehmen
dass man irgendwie diese offenheit
behält und da eben mal duschen geht und
wartet bis etwas einfällt ich gehe jeden
tag durch manchmal zu lange aus
ökologischen gründen aber ich glaube
schon dass man sich die zeit nehmen
sollte tatsächlich und sie haben
natürlich recht es ist so alltäglich ist
es nicht gegeben sondern diesen freiraum
muss man trainieren man könnte sagen
dass es wie eine art von innovations-
meditation die man vielleicht sich
selber auferlegen müsste oder könnte um
um diese räume zu schaffen und damit
offen zu sein aber auch sozusagen die
netzwerkfunktionen des geistes wirklich
nutzen und sich entwickeln lassen zu
können
weil wenn man nicht auf etwas
hinarbeitet und sich auf etwas konkretes
konzentriert kann man ja extrem gut
sozusagen in den eigenen gedanken dinge
zusammenbringen die eigentlich nicht
zusammengehören und das ist auch ob ein
im prinzip mit dem city hervorgebracht
wird also ich habe ganz oft zb
journalistische ideen für themen oder
auch forschungsideen für
forschungsprojekte die nicht aus
wissenschaftlichen oder journalistischen
mädchen kommen sondern die auf literatur
kommen was literatur plötzlich mir ein
gedanke kommt da gibt es dann
verschiedene stufen die dazwischen sind
bis ich dann zu dem eigentlichen
anwendungsfall oder dem der der
journalistischen oder der forschungs
frage komme aber diese vernetzungs
möglichkeit diese offenheit muss man
nutzen und dass das ist im alltag etwas
was ich nicht automatisch ergibt sondern
dafür muss man sorge tragen
ja und jetzt vielleicht auch also wenn
ich so auf mein eigenes leben blicke
vielleicht auch eine frage von
lebensphasen weil ich finde es gibt
schon auch so lebensphasen wo das
loslassen einfach schwerer fällt also
wenn man noch ganz ungesichert
ungesicherten boden hat beruflich und
und irgendwie überhaupt erstmal einen
anfang schaffen muss und da ist es ja
auch wichtig tatsächlich dieses dran
bleiben und dieses irgendwie auch
hartnäckig sein und auch so eine ebenso
ein gewisses maß an verkrampfungen wenn
man so will auch in kauf zu nehmen und
ich also ich merke dass mir das je älter
ich werde desto leichter fällt mir das
eigentlich so dieses kommt jetzt lasst
lassen das mal gut sein jetzt gehe ich
mal spazieren oder ich mach irgendwas
anderes und das hat glaube ich schon
auch was zu tun mit seiner weiß nicht
vielleicht irgendwie selbstsicherheit
oder reife oder wie man auch immer das
land mit vielleicht noch eine andere
gedanke es kann jetzt schon schon
häufiger und das stimmt natürlich auch
zufällig liest man etwas und dann kommt
man auf den gedanken und ich habe
manchmal aber auch das gefühl dass das
der gedanke immer gekommen wäre
durch was auch immer also das ist
sozusagen nur ein anlass braucht damit
der gedanke der da in mir drin sitzt
rauskommen kann ob das jetzt dann ein
bestimmtes buch ist oder ob das
vielleicht ein irgendwas ist was ich
draußen sehe oder ein gespräch musik mit
einem jagst vielleicht genau man braucht
irgendwas was es worauf wir raus holt
also was sagen ja zumindest braucht sind
sicher schon mal die rahmenbedingungen
also noch einmal das beispiel von
columbus wenn der nicht an sich
überhaupt losgesegelt wäre hätte er
überhaupt nichts entdeckt
oder wenn der fleming nicht angefangen
hätte da irgendwelche kulturen zu
entwickeln dann wäre da auch kein
schimmelpilz gewachsen
aufgrund dessen er nachher das
penicillin entdeckt hätte also das
braucht man ja schon aber wenn jetzt
noch einmal vielleicht auch an die
innovationspolitik denken wie entsteht
eigentlich neues in der welt neues auch
in der wissenschaft wie es die schweiz
ist weltmeister in der innovation sagt
man immer wir sind stolz auf das
innovative potenzial der schweiz
was müsste sich da denn ändern oder was
müsste gegeben sein dass innovation
besser noch möglich ist
es gibt ein schönes schönes modell das
das dazu passt dass das schweizer käse
modell der winter petit und das
beschreibt
barrieren gut was sie gerade gefragt
haben also wenn man sich vorstellt man
hat verschiedene dicke scheiben
schweizer käse dann sind da überall
löcher drin
und die müssen schon so zueinander
liegen dass man irgendwann einen pfeil
durch schießen kann und der genau durch
die konstruktion der löcher fliegt also
es muss sozusagen eine richtige
konstellation von gegebenheiten geben um
innovation wirklich möglich zu machen
wenn man es auch innovationspolitik
bezieht dann glaube ich ist es natürlich
hat es damit zu tun dass die
forschungslandschaft so sein muss dass
die in die richtige richtung entwickelt
das die freiräume gegeben sind das die
forschungsgelder gegeben sind
es wird wahrscheinlich etwas zu tun
haben mit dem ganzen venture capital
market dem angebot für gründungskapital
den den hoffentlich niedrigen
bürokratischen hürden für
unternehmensgründungen
es wird was zu tun haben auch mit einem
umfeld einer liberalen gesellschaft wie
erlaubt dass man eben nicht in
schachteln denkt oder in schubladen
alles sofort einordnen sondern eben aus
diesem schubladen raus geht also das
kann man schon in faktoren
durchdeklinieren jeder noch eine
systemische servern tippe die möglich
machen und dass er oft kritisiert wird
in letzter zeit ist dieses so genannte
prinzip publish or perish also die
forschenden die unter einem enormen
druck stehen möglichst schnell möglichst
viel zu publizieren was sie eigentlich
dazu zwingt das was sie mal
herausgefunden haben immer nur
geringfügig zu verändern und gleich
wieder ein neues papier zu gießen statt
mal sozusagen im leeren raum das ganz
neue zu wagen und eben auch sagen wir
mal drei wochen lang fast nur zu duschen
und zugucken passiert da was das ist
eigentlich fast nicht mehr möglich
ja ich ja also ich wenn ich mich so
dunkel zurück erinnere an meine
akademische zeit dann würde ich sogar
sagen dass das akademische arbeiten in
sich der kreativität also zumindest ein
stück weit auch wirklich das wasser
abgräbt also ich weiß noch dass
natürlich verlangt wird dass man erst
mal so einen fußnoten apparat also
sozusagen alles rezipiert was vorher zu
diesem thema gesagt wurde und dann darf
man sich vielleicht so ein millimeter
über den forschungsstand hinauswagen
aber das muss man auch alles noch ganz
genau belegen
das heißt so diese hat dieser
gedankliche freiraum einfach mal und
damit meine ich jetzt nicht im sinne von
dass es haltlos wäre das darum geht es
gar nicht aber das dass das neue zu
denken heißt eben nicht dass ich mich
erstmal dass ich erstmal in zehnseitigen
fußnoten apparat schreiben muss sondern
ich muss überhaupt erst mal zu denken
lernen was heißt denken das ist die
frage was heißt eigentlich denken und
darum geht's herzlich wenig muss ich
sagen ein stein hätte sich glaube ich
wenn er könnte über unser heutiges
wissenschaftssystem totgelacht einfach
weil es genau so eben nicht funktioniert
damit will ich nicht die ganzen
leistungen der forscherinnen und
forschern frage ist doch wie es gibt
also man muss das schon differenziert
sehen aber wenig provokativ sein wollte
könnte ich sagen
dieses ganze publish or perish system
ist eigentlich das system einer fake
währung ja die dahin führt dass man eben
eigentlich am besten in einer sehr engen
schiene immer dasselbe in kleinen
varianten tut um möglichst viel output
zu produzieren und das hat mit
innovationen oder kreativität an vielen
stellen dann tatsächlich nichts mehr zu
tun und versuchen sie als professorin
das irgendwie anders zu machen
na ja ich versuche den studentinnen und
studenten schulden zu signalisieren dass
ich nicht der überzeugung bin dass das
der richtige weg ist
aber wenn man ehrlich ist muss man
denjenigen denen die wissenschaft wollen
heute sagen du musst eigentlich lieber
angepasst sein als dass du mutig bis
neue ergebnisse zu produzieren also wenn
man öffentlich finanzierten
forschungsantrag macht der auf ganz viel
aufbaut was da ist und nicht sehr sehr
innovativ ist hat man unter umständen
sehr viel größere chancen das geld
zugesprochen zu bekommen
also wenn man wirklich was neues wagt
und das da ist eine unwucht drin von der
ich glaube dass das wir sie wirklich
überdenken müssten weil das auf dauer
nicht gut tut und auch viele motivierte
junge leute wirklich abhält davon in
diesem bereich zu gehen etwas was ich
unglaublich interessant finde ist wenn
man sich auch überlegt wissenschaftlich
dass er exakt und aus einem text von
ihren vorschlag köhler den sieben
philosophie magazin geschrieben haben
habe ich eine idee habe ich eine idee
entdeckt per zufall
die stammt vom bio physik
nobelpreisträger max delbrück und zwar
hat er das prinzip der begrenzten
schlampigkeit geprägt das zitieren sie
da und er versteht darunter diese idee
dass man experimental systeme nicht bis
ans ende festzurren sollte sondern man
muss auch ein bisschen schlampig sein
und ich habe mich dann gefragt wie
verhält sich denn diese schlampigkeit
zur exaktheit die die wissenschaften das
denken und gerade die philosophie ja
auch von uns erfordern
ja ich denke man muss tatsächlich diese
beiden dinge die auch daher die
eigentlich nicht zusammen gehören
zusammen bringen also natürlich muss man
im denken exakt sein also eben kein kein
haltloses denken produzieren aber
schlampig seien eben auch insofern als
dass man sich dass man sich eben lösen
können muss von dem was vorher gedacht
wurde dass man dass man aus bricht aus
diesen aus diesen bahnen in denen bisher
gedacht wurde und sich exakt daran hält
und dass ein anderer sagt kommt weg
damit ich glaube ich weiß gar nicht was
schopenhauer hat er gesagt hat das was
andere gedacht haben und jetzt wird so
ein bisschen vulgär das was andere
gedacht haben ist beschissene scheiße
hat schopenhauer glaube ich mal
geschrieben und er hat das einfach mal
so vom tisch gewischt und und
möglicherweise braucht man diese geste
eben auch um zu sagen da da fängt dann
denken eben auch an ich will es mal kurz
alles runter und ich gebe mir raum und
ich würde sagen das hat das hat schon
auch was mit so einem mann mit mut ganz
viel zu tun aber eben auch mit einem
jahr mit einem schönsten sinne
laissez-faire dass das einmal passieren
es ist auch ein bisschen was
menschliches drin in diesem bemühen um
exaktheit also was wir tun ja in der
wissenschaft auch ganz oft oder ehrlich
gesagt auch im alltag an vielen stellen
ist dass wir uns modelle bilden für das
was kompliziert ist in der wirklichkeit
das versuchen wir in der kompliziertheit
irgendwie ein bisschen einfacher zu
machen dem modell draus machen was dann
natürlich nicht ganz akkurat ist und
nicht ganz genau die komplexität der
eigentlich dargestellten wirklichkeit
spiegelt und das ist auch in ordnung
finde ich um sozusagen einen kleinen
bereich raus zu greifen und zu sagen das
gucken wir uns genauer an und dafür
nehmen wir jetzt mal dieses reduzierte
modell nur wenn der grundgedanke dabei
ist dass das modell
wirklich stimmt und wir nicht mehr
bereit sind zu sagen eigentlich ist kein
modell eine eine reflexion der
wirklichkeit ja der map ist mit
territorial fred kollwitz key die die
die landkarte ist niemals die landschaft
wenn ich versuche eine landkarte so
genau zu machen dass sie die landschaft
widerspiegelt wird sie riesig und
komplett unbrauchbar und es war sofort
veraltet und da habe ich das gefühl sind
wir gerade auf dem falschen weg weil wir
eben genau versuchen diese exaktheit
permanent zu verbessern und damit uns
selbst unbrauchbar machen in der
beobachtung dessen was wir gar nicht
beschreiben wollen
es gibt auch so ein bisschen in die
kritik von big data rein um dieses ganze
durch algorithmen sierte leben darüber
sprechen wir später noch ich würde gerne
mal wissen ins lebensweltliche
reinkommen sie beide ihre leben würden
sie sagen ist das in erster linie harte
arbeit viel zufall oder schicksal von
sie anfangen würde ist natürlich kein
zufall weil frauen immer dazu neigen
ganz oft zu sagen dass alles was
gelungen ist zufall ist
aber jetzt ernsthaft es ist sicher auch
zufall dabei und kein mensch kann
behaupten dass nicht zufall eine rolle
gespielt hat bei mir zum beispiel ist es
so dass ich das einzige was ich jemals
in meinem leben werden wollte nicht
geschafft habe und nicht geworden bin
nämlich auslandskorrespondenten in china
und alles andere was ich nicht gewollt
aber habe ich dann irgendwie hingekriegt
also ganz so ist es nicht ich wollte
schon ein paar sachen die ich in meinem
leben gemacht habe
aber es ist immer eine mischung und ich
glaube die die anstrengung ist schon
dabei aber nicht die anstrengung
jedenfalls ist das bei mir so weil
meinen lebenslauf auch ein bisschen
serendipity ist die anstrengung auf
etwas spezifisches was ich dann
erreichen wollte das war nicht so als
wäre er die anstrengung ich wirklich mit
einem themenfeld auseinanderzusetzen was
mich von anfang an fasziniert hat
nämlich kommunikation und da mich dann
auch wirklich darauf zu konzentrieren
und ganz viel zu lesen und zu denken und
so und daraus haben sich dann
opportunitäten ergeben die ich einzeln
so nicht geplant und angestrebt habe die
aber entstanden sind
vielleicht muss man da zunächst einmal
auch noch mal sagen dass das der zufall
ja auch etwas sehr
das ist ja was sehr kompliziert ist also
was ist eigentlich zufallen
eigentlich könnte man sagen und das
schließt an leibnitz an also einem
philosophen
es ist überhaupt nichts zufall sondern
wir haben möglicherweise nur noch nicht
genau verstanden was der eigentliche
plan dahinter ist und so weiter und
natürlich kann man es so sagen das bild
der komplett der terminiert naturgesetze
bei leibnitz natürlich auch noch gott
der seine hände im spiel hatte aber
heute in einer wissenschaftlichen welt
würde sagen es ist alles von
naturgesetzen bestimmt genau
oder man oder man sagt jetzt auch in
unser beider leben ich würde auch sagen
ist es wahnsinnig viel zufall dabei aber
natürlich kann man alles erklären also
man könnte auf der einen seite sagen
dass es mich überhaupt gibt ist ein
riesen zu fall
dass jetzt ausgerechnet diese samenzelle
schneller war bei der zeugung und ich
die wurde die ich bin ist ein
wahnsinniger zufall aber wahrscheinlich
kann man tatsächlich genau erklären
warum diese eine samenzelle schneller
war als die andere
also damit man kannst du sagen wir von
welcher seite auch immer man es anschaut
das ist einmal total krasser zufall und
auf der anderen seite ist es halt alles
irgendwie erklären genau aber ich glaube
wir müssen ja wirklich genau sein also
ich hab ich habe noch einen würfel
mitgenommen
also wenn ich jetzt hier wird dann ist
das genau glaube ich ein gutes beispiel
für das zufallsprinzip
also das heißt ich kann nicht
voraussehen dass das ne 4 gibt sie auch
nicht das ist zufall dass ich nie vier
gewürfelt habe das heißt nicht dass
nicht die naturgesetze gespielt haben
aber es ist nicht fair dass
wahrscheinlichkeit prinzip weil ich habe
sozusagen die möglichkeit dass es eins
zwei drei vier fünf oder sechs wird ich
habe nicht die möglichkeit dass es
sieben wirklich nur ein würfel habe das
ist absolut richtig und trotzdem würden
wir sagen es ist natürlich zufall dass
es nicht viel wurde oder wenn wir zur
alltagssprache ich sprechen würden wir
so dass statt der fall gespielt oder was
entscheidet zum beispiel auch obwohl wir
natürlich erklären können nicht dazu
kommt endgültig noch die quantenphysik
dazu nehmen und sagen na ja unsere welt
ist sowieso nicht gänzlich der
terminiert auch physikalisch gesehen
gibt den zufall aber darüber wollen wir
jetzt gar nicht sprechen es geht darum
dieses lebensweltliche ding und dauert
mir ja gerne wissen wie ich jetzt mit
ihm reden braucht also wieder davon
haben
ich wirklich mühe gegeben den würfel
richtig so zu werfen dass die vier raus
kommt und wie viel würden sie sagen ja
da bin ich so hingefallen
ja ich würde sagen es ist im schönsten
sinne dialektisch ist es wirklich beides
greift beides ineinander also natürlich
habe ich ganz es gibt ganz viel um
verfügbares in meinem leben dass ich
nicht selbst bestimmen konnte
und das kann man ja sagen es wirklich
das ist ja wirklich ein gegensatz das
was ich selbst bestimmen kann was ich
verfügen kann und das was ich nicht
verfügen kann und das würden wir er dann
immer als zufälligkeit begreifen also
dass ich konkret ich jetzt mit einem
gesunden körper als frau im westen in
einem reichen land zur welt gekommen bin
im jahre 1975 kann ich nicht verfügen
das konnte ich nicht verfügen das ist
zufall dass sich die kindheit hatte die
ich hatte das konnte ich auch nicht
wirklich verfügen auch das ist in
gewisser weise auch wenn man es erklären
kann ist es mir zugefallen
und insofern gibt es ganz ganz viele
zufälle in meinem leben dinge die ich
nicht nicht oder nur geringfügig
beeinflussen konnte aber ich glaube dass
man ja trotzdem an bestimmten stellen
seines lebens auch entscheidungen
treffen muss und dieses entscheiden
müssen also ab vor dem hintergrund einer
bestimmten kontingents ist jetzt die
lager und ich muss mich jetzt
entscheiden wenig oder wähle ich b und
das ist dann tatsächlich sehr das liegt
dann in mir und an mir und interessant
finde ich übrigens ich weiß nicht sie
haben vielleicht haben sie auch fällt
ihnen auch sofort etwas eine
existenzielle entscheidung mache ich
jetzt die den beruf oder mache ich den
beruf kriege ich kinder kriege ich keine
dass in dem augenblick wenn man sich
entscheidet dass man eigentlich ganz bei
sich ist so so sehr bei sich wie sonst
überhaupt nie und dass ich genau in
diesen momenten immer das gefühl hatte
ich gucke mich von außen an also ich bin
gar nicht wie ich gucke mich von außen
an aha so entscheidest du dich jetzt und
die frage ist er tatsächlich auch
entscheide ich wirklich oder trifft die
entscheidung mich also dieses phänomen
der entscheidung finde ich hängt mit und
dem thema haben es wäre gerade
besprechen sehr sehr eng zusammen das
ist ja das ist er auch sozusagen
neurowissenschaftlich total interessant
ja was glauben die eigentlich mit blick
auf unsere entscheidungen wie viel
rein willen wir haben und wie viel ist
dann tatsächlich schon da was wir
eigentlich sozusagen für uns selbst als
freie entscheidung legitimieren nach dem
motto im nachhinein finde ich mir ein
schicksal was dann auch eine schöne
story telling ist und ignoriere dass da
vielleicht ganz andere faktoren rolle
gespielt haben
für etwas was sich so entwickelt hat und
vielleicht doch bis in den termin ist
ischer war als ich das selber glaube
kann kann auch seien absolut und und was
was finde ich auch noch mal ein
wichtiges stichwort ist generationen die
erzählung also dass wir uns unser leben
im nachhinein erzählen weil wir ja
tatsächlich sehr dazu neigen eigentlich
in generation unseres eigenen selbst den
zufall mehr oder weniger zu eliminieren
also es macht dann ja im rückblick macht
ja alles irgendwie sinn und das ist mein
lebensweg und dann hat sich das so und
es ergibt sich alles so organischen also
man beschönigt vielleicht auch im
nachhinein das ein oder andere das
selbst vielleicht etwas was gar nicht so
toll war trotzdem gut war für dieses
oder jenes so also diese nachträglich
generation ist wirklich ein zufalls
killer wenn man so will und das finde
ich jetzt aber sehr interessant sind die
eigentlich beim thema freiheit gelandet
und tatsächlich könnte man ja sagen das
thema freiheit das können die eigentlich
uns nur bewahren denn ein stückweit
sagen den zu vermissen wie ich auch zu
ernst nehmen also das meist entscheiden
wir dann doch noch selber wir sind die
herren im eigenen haus das war der punkt
auf denen sie hinaus wollten als sie
gesagt haben
wir versuchen dann doch zu sagen ich war
diejenige die den entscheid gefällt hat
und nicht irgendwie ein zufälliges
synapsen den körper im hirn
das stimmt ich überlege jetzt nur gerade
ob ich das wirklich so gemeint habe wie
ist gesagt habe ich glaube das ist schon
so dass man natürlich eine form von von
entscheidungsmöglichkeit braucht das ist
ja auch das was was man in der ganzen
philosophischen diskussionen um den
freien willen als dass das baby
sozusagen beschreibt dass man also
selbst wenn bestimmte
entscheidungsprozesse eigentlich
neurologisch schon schon stattfinden
messbar stattfinden bevor man selber
realisiert dass man die entscheidung
trifft gibt es die möglichkeit dazu sage
ich mach's doch nicht ja und das ist
sozusagen der teil der freiheit der uns
bleibt den ich auch relativ wichtig
finde ich glaube aber dass die freiheit
auch darin neben deshalb würde ich dem
zufall jetzt nicht gerne hier diesen an
stelle liegt auch darin dass man für
sich selber sagt ich lasse zu dass er
mich findet und ich glaube damit darin
ist auch ein stück freiheit weil wenn
ich mich total auf alles konzentriere
bin ich komplett verschlossen für dinge
die ich nicht gesucht oder erwartet habe
und eigentlich entstehen darauf so viele
gute sachen dass das auch ein teil der
freiheit ist die ich gerne hätte
das ist das aber eine schöne dialektik
dass die freiheit genau darin besteht
den zufall also dass was ich nicht
verfüge zuzulassen
also ich finde interessant was jetzt
gesagt haben sozusagen zuzulassen dass
das mich dann findet und sie hatten am
anfang dieses diesen punkt erwähnt dass
sie glauben wenn sie irgendein buch
schreiben das dieser gedanke ohnehin
irgendwann aus ihnen rausgekommen wäre
für mich liegen beide ideen seien ganz
klein bisschen nach der idee des
schicksals so als gäbe es da doch noch
sowas vorbestimmt das etwas was sein
muss etwas was mich dann schon
irgendwann finden wird wenn ich heute
dann morgen ja also ich ertappe mich
zumindest dabei ich bin wirklich
überhaupt nicht praktizieren gläubig
oder so aber ich ertappe mich schon
dabei dass ich so ganz von so einem
führungs gedanken gar nicht lassen kann
also dass man irgendwie also irgendwas
sperrt sich in mir auf jeden fall mich
so als reine kontingents zu sehen was
dann ja auch ganz schnell zu seiner
ironischen sarkastischen welt haltung
führt irgendwie ist eh alles wurscht ist
er lässt zufall wir sterben sowieso
sondern dass es das schon etwas gibt ja
was was was was ich gut fügt oder also
wenn man zum beispiel einem menschen
begegnet dass man sagt mensch das war
jetzt aber eine schöne fügung dass wir
uns begegnet sind und warum warum denke
ich dass in dem moment weil irgendwas in
mir da zu funkeln anfängt weil da
irgendwas geweckt wird und das was da in
mir drin ist was da was da so funkelt
oder zu funkeln anfängt in dem
augenblick oder auch wenn man schreibt
oder oder den gedanken hat oder so
dieses funkeln dass das ist doch schon
mehr als einfach nur kontingent oder
oder könnte so sein könnte nicht so in
sondern das ist da und das hat sowas
leicht metaphysisches und das ist nicht
interessant sie sagen einerseits glauben
sie eigentlich nicht als schicksal oder
sie sind nicht gläubig aber an
sagen sie lebenspraktisch gesehen
brauchen wir diese idee sonst werden die
in die zynisch oder sarkastisch
ja und das ist auch eine form von
händlern entlastungsfunktion die glaube
ich darin liegt dass die dass das
bewusstsein dass jeder moment den ich in
meinem leben erlebe für mich und
möglicherweise auch für andere menschen
in meiner verantwortung liegt ist ja
schon auch eine form von würde und ich
finde das schon richtig das zu nehmen
mit einem mit einer liberalen weltsicht
hat jeder dann schon auch ein stück
anteil an seinem eigenen leben mit den
entscheidungen die er oder sie trifft
aber das ist auch elemente geben kann
die was transzendentale es haben ob man
das jetzt göttlich religiös köstlich wie
auch immer interpretiert ganz egal
die menschen vielleicht verbinden diese
momente die einen selbst vielleicht mit
einer lebens umwelt verbinden die man
eben nicht alle im griff halten kann
dass das finde ich auf der einen seite
ein stück entlastung von dieser
anforderung und ich empfinde es auch als
ein als ein neugier speicher und eine
offenheit speicher in dem man sozusagen
immer wieder eintauchen kann sagen kann
ach ja es gibt auch noch ganz andere
dimensionen die ich jetzt mal nicht
entschieden habe das ist glaube ich für
den menschen er auch ganz ganz gesund
oder so und hier sehen und diese
dialektik der freiheit ist ja in der tat
waren sie nicht interessant also wir
haben auf der einen seite gesagt
freiheit das eigene leben gestalten zu
können und nicht total abhängig zu sein
ich ein von spielball des zufalls oder
des schicksals zu sein das wollen wir
uns behaupten das zeichnet das moderne
denken ja auch aus ich kann etwas aus
mir machen
ich habe mein leben in der hand und
gleichzeitig ist es eine bürde
mir gefällt auch sehr dieses bild von
sloterdijk mit dem atlas komplex dass er
sagt der moderne mensch schuld hat seine
welt und die übel der welt wie der titan
outlaws in der griechischen mythologie
der das himmels gewölbe tragen musste
und er bricht da eigentlich auch dauernd
fasst zusammen das ist auch einfach
wahnsinnig schwer wenn man alles aus
einem zustößt sich selber zuschreiben
müssen ja es hat auch was von
allmachtsfantasien
also von seinem grandiosität gedanken
dass alles von mir abhängt und das
belastet einen sehr und das hat auch
sogar was also passiert ist ist wenn man
so will also deshalb finde ich auch und
das klingt jetzt vielleicht auch wieder
so ein bisschen metaphysisch religiös
also diese diese haltung der der
dankbarkeit auch also gegenüber
bestimmten zufällen oder und
verfügbarkeiten eben zum beispiel dass
ich in diesem land geboren bin in dem
ich geboren bin
oder auch dass ich das kind meiner
eltern bin
das kann ein mit dankbarkeit erfüllen
und insofern glaube ich es ist
vielleicht tatsächlich ja eine dreiheit
die da immer eine rolle spielt natürlich
müssen wir dinge selbst entscheiden wir
müssen wie es ja so schön heißt kairos
beim schopfe packen also den moment
nutzen und irgendwas daraus machen und
warum mache ich das ja weil ich
irgendwie das gefühl habe das ist jetzt
richtig ist hat was mit intuition und in
ihrer stimme zu tun
dann finde ich aber eben auch diese
dieses diese dieses wissen darum dass
ich nicht alles verfüge sondern dass es
vielleicht auch fügungen gibt also sich
sich da auch ein stück weit zu entlasten
das hat ja auch etwas historisches also
die story dieses nur das unverfügbare
versucht gar nicht erst oder nimm es
einfach mal hin was du nicht verfügen
kannst und dann aber drittens
tatsächlich bei alldem trotzdem auch die
radikale kontingents zu sehen also die
ja was eben dann vielleicht auch etwas
leicht zynisch es haben kann in manchen
augenblicken oder die uns vielleicht
auch hilft uns nicht allzu wichtig zu
nehmen so als wäre das ja immer so schön
heißt so wimpernschlag in der geschichte
vielleicht sind es wirklich diese drei
elemente die man in irgendeiner form in
sonne in so ein zusammenspiel bringen
muss aber wenn ihr mal angefangen haben
das gottvertrauen stärker durch ein
selbstvertrauen zu ersetzen haben wir
nicht schon so eine linie überschritten
wo wir eigentlich schlecht wieder zurück
können also sie beide plädieren jetzt
ein bisschen dafür so einen schicksals
gedanken noch zu retten und einzubauen
aber vielleicht bleibt es letztlich ein
bisschen künstlich für all die menschen
die wirklich nicht gläubig sind und das
ist nun festhalten an einer idee oder ja
ich meine es hat auch oder wollten es
hat ja auch
man könnte sich auch fragen ob wir uns
das in zukunft überhaupt
noch leisten können weil je mehr wir
natürlich verfügen können also ich denke
gerade auch so an den ganzen
bioethischen bereich diese krispl
geschichte das dass die gen scheren
wir können ja business gehen materialien
genau und ich meine es ist ja wirklich
so dass das man sich vorstellen kann
dass irgendwann kinder zu einem sagen
mensch mama warum hast du denn nicht die
gehen scherer angewendet warum habe ich
jetzt diese oder jene krankheit also
dieses konfrontiert werden einfach damit
mit der möglichkeit verfügen zu können
also das fängt ja schon bei der
schwangerschaft an geht dann weiter es
also diese möglichkeit verfügen zu
können die wird ja immer stärker ob wir
das wollen oder nicht und dazu müssen
wir uns ja irgendwie verhalten aber
können wir da noch zurück das sind ja
eigentlich auch wieder bei der
wissenschaft können wir wieder zurück
und sagen lasst uns wieder den zufall
spielen also ich glaube wir können schon
ein stück zurück und ich beobachte dass
im moment auch wenn ich das ist auch gar
kein zufall dass wir jetzt auch darüber
reden weil wenn wir das gespräch
schuldigen jahren eingeführte internet
ich glaube ich nicht über solche momente
der fügung oder so gesprochen weil ich
einfach nicht dran geglaubt hätte
tatsächlich und mein gefühl ist dass
sich das verändert hat ich weiß dass es
sich für mich selber ein stück weit
verändert hat aber ich glaube es hat
sich auch in der gesellschaft verändert
er beginnt sich zu verändern ich glaube
das ist eine reaktion auf das was wir
ansonsten sehen chris bourque es all die
genetischen manipulationsmöglichkeiten
sind das eine big data haben sie eben
angesprochen ist das andere
wir bewegen uns ja schon im moment in
einer gesellschaft hinein die eine
komplett durch mathematisierung
gesellschaft wird und wo auch der mensch
an vielen stellen eine durch
mathematisierung funktion wird die der
idealerweise irgendwie funktioniert wenn
man irgendwas an drückt auf dem
smartphone oder wo auch immer und dann
passiert ickx und wenn ich das aus mache
passiert y
und das ist natürlich ein menschenbild
was da entsteht eines mathematischen
menschen denen übrigens robert musil und
213 schon in einem sehr schönen
gleichnamigen text beschrieben hat
dieses bild ist nicht menschlich weil
wir nicht so funktionieren sondern wir
haben uns ja auch randomisierte
bestandteile die sich zufällig wichtige
bestandteile die in entscheidungen
reingreifen die unser leben eingreifen
und das ist manchmal auch tatsächlich
ganz gut so weil wenn
die damit genau erklären sie das damit
meine ich dass in allem was wir
entscheiden ja auch sozusagen emotionale
und und intuitive möser auch gefühl
impulse eine rolle spielen da kann man
jetzt auch wieder darüber streiten ob
das auch deterministisch ist oder nicht
ich glaube dass es sowas gibt auch liebe
es sicherlich nichts was man an oder
ausknipsen kann ich kann nicht jemanden
entwerfen und sagen bislang fand ich den
blöd jetzt mache ich das und das und das
und jetzt passt sind jetzt verliebe ich
mich funktioniert einfach nicht
und deshalb sind diese bestandteile im
leben da und wenn wir hingehen und auf
basis von daten und auf
biotechnologischen möglichkeiten einem
automatisierten gesellschaft entwerfen
wo alles nur noch eine funktion zwischen
xy ist dann ist das unmenschlich einer
bestimmten stelle und ich glaub wir
haben die gegenbewegung die beginnt die
eben genau sich darauf konzentriert dass
diese anderen bestandteile intuition
fügung emotionen dass die wieder stärker
eine rolle spielen weil man sich auch
ein bisschen danach sehnt nicht
betrachtet zu werden wie eine maschine
ganz mensch und da sind wir auch wieder
bei der bei dem neuen woher kommt das
neue also das exakt durchkalkulierte
oder bei dem was sie am anfang sagt mit
der exaktheit und der schlampigkeit also
das exakt durchkalkulierte und ja eben
auch vorhersehbare kann überhaupt nichts
neues sicher eignen weil es ist ja alle
hat ja alles in irgendeiner weise eine
eine mathematische funktion und ich sehe
das so ähnlich also ich würde auch sagen
nehmen wir jetzt mal so eine digitale
partnerbörse oder so die algorithmen
basiert zwei menschen irgendwie zusammen
bringt aber verlieben muss ich mich
immer noch selber das kam mir diese
börse ja nicht ab was ich habe mir nur
dass statt nur nachgewiesenermaßen
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich gut durch diese
pausen über diese börsen sprechen weil
ich finde das eigentlich interessantes
phänomen
es gibt eine partnerschaft börse oder so
ein algorithmus ein programm das wird
mit dem zufall liebherr mit dem slogan
liebe ist kein zufall
und das ist natürlich genau die idee
dahinter je mehr daten nicht da ein gebe
je größer die datenbank ist desto höher
die trefferquote für den perfekten match
was spricht dagegen nichts mit erstmal
nichts also ich bin über jeden menschen
der ein andere menschen findet mit dem
er oder sie glücklich ist bin ich bin
ich froh
tatsächlich sehen wir dass die die
ergebnisse der partnerschafts börse
nicht so schlecht sind also
möglicherweise nur zwei dinge
unterscheiden ob es so was gibt wie eine
ein matching zwischen menschen wo
bestimmte eigenschaften die die
komplementär auch vielleicht
konfrontativ sein können passen und
deshalb entsteht liebe dass das eine das
andere ist wie begegne ich diesen
menschen und in der analogen welt in der
wir bis vor weil sie sich 20 jahren
gelebt haben musste man darauf warten
dass man auf einer party in der tram in
der uni wo auch immer diesen menschen
begegnet der vielleicht passt und dass
dieses begegnen ist sozusagen jetzt der
herr logisch operationalisieren worden
durch algorithmen die menschliche
eigenschaften so menschen dass sich die
menschen finden die vielleicht gut
zusammenpassen und gleichzeitig ein
bisschen so eine rückkehr zur vernunft
also die frage ist ja auch mal vorüber
worüber reden wir von liebe reden also
ist das ist das jetzt die die wahnsinnig
sozusagen brodelnde erotische begegnung
oder oder ist es einfach wirklich so
okay da werden leute zusammengebracht
die haben bringen bestimmte skills mit
mit denen sie irgendwie gut ihr leben
zusammen verbringen können ja wie
schönere liebe ist die die nicht so
vernünftig ist oder ja das stimmt
das schicksals mächtig in der liebe
diese idee an der also die gesamte
hollywood industrie basiert ja auf
dieser idee dass zwei zusammengehören
müssen sie beide leben in langjährigen
beziehungen sehen sie das selber eher
aus zufall oder haben sie den perfekten
match den guten schachzug selber gemacht
oder war es zufall kann es auch jemand
anders sein natürlich nicht genau der
andere guckt zu und biss vielleicht
enttäuscht natürlich ist natürlich hätte
es kann ja auch ein anderer ist will ich
hätte es jemand anders sein können das
würde ich wirklich so sagen alle ja ja
natürlich also dass es hat natürlich
etwas zufälliges dass man sich eben dass
man sich begegnet auch noch in einer
situation begegnet die die hinreichend
offen war dass man was draus machen
konnte dass man selber offen war das
sind alles zufälligkeiten also das würde
ich in jedem fall
aber ob es trägt ob man zusammen bleiben
kann ob man sich gemeinsam entwickelt
und so weiter davon entlastet mich auch
keine partnerbörse das muss ich
irgendwie hinkriegen mit diesem anderen
mensch und da ist auch wieder die frage
der perspektive nicht natürlich kann es
wahrscheinlich jemand anders sein aber
man kann sich trotzdem in der beziehung
so fühlen das urbane toni gefunden ist
auch wenn man weiß dass es
möglicherweise noch andere menschen
hätte geben können mit denen was
ähnliches möglich gewesen wäre
warum zieht man sich dann so man bietet
sich das einfach hinnehmen bildet sich
nicht ein sondern es ist die situation
weil das eine frage wegen wie ich mein
leben definiert wenn ich das wenn ich
auf mein leben cook und sage ich suche
jetzt eigentlich immer nach dem absolut
perfekten match dann werde ich sehr sehr
unglücklich sein mein ganzes leben
langweilig werde dieses perfekte match
niemals finden und ich musste aus dem
moment heraus leben und dass deutschland
im moment kann möglicherweise auch 16
jahre lang sein und sagen so fühlt es
sich an ja und da kann es kann sein dass
es an anderer stelle jemand anders
gegeben hätte und das anders noch
aufrecht bürger noch toller gelaufen
wäre
aber ich bin doch glücklich hier an der
stelle und das hat auch was damit zu tun
dass nicht durch zum automatisieren zu
sagen wo ist die perfektion so lange
suche ich und wenn ich vorher sterbe
habe ich pech gehabt also das ist ja
grauenhaft uns im leben wie viel zum
thema liebe und zertifikat noch eine
geschichte ein die sehr durch die medien
ging in den letzten monaten und zwar hat
die schweiz sich erinnert an das
flugzeugunglück vor harry fox und da
gibt es die geschichte von zwei menschen
die sich gefunden haben die beiden
sozusagen zurückgebliebene partner
partnerin waren also ihre jeweiligen
partner sind umgekommen und die haben
sich kennengelernt an einem solchen
anlass in dem es darum gehen gemeinsam
zu trauern und sich ineinander verliebt
das ist eigentlich serie bietet im leben
oder tal total die die umstände sind
gegeben weil das das schicksal nämlich
dieser flugzeugabsturz die beiden
sozusagen gleich betroffen hat und
irgendwie müssen sie dann auch offen
gewesen sein sich emotional wieder
einzulassen und trotzdem werden die sich
wahrscheinlich nie begegnet ohne diese
voraussetzungen also das ist ein
unheimlich schönes beispiel finde ich
vielleicht noch mal zurück zu diesem one
and only
ich würde sogar so weit gehen und sagen
dass dieses segment only und das ist ne
daraus folgt ja ganz viel das ist
schützenswert ich kümmere mich darum ich
pflege dass ich ich bin wenn da und so
weiter dass das vielleicht auch ein
stück weit eine notwendige fiktion ist
weil natürlich ist es in gewisser weise
in einer gewissen perspektive viel
rationaler zu denken hey klar kann es
jemanden geben der noch besser zu mir
passt es ist sogar sehr wahrscheinlich
wenn ich mir alle menschen der welt
irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise versuche
zur gegenwehr zu vergegenwärtigen
vielleicht hätte ich mit dem dieses
problem nicht mit dem das nicht und so
weiter aber es erzeugt natürlich eine
ganz neue komplexität also ich glaube
insofern ist es vielleicht auch letzten
endes auch wieder eine entscheidung so
ein bisschen und das soll sich jetzt gar
nicht irgendwie kalt oder pragmatisch
anhören aber wie man sein leben
verbringen will ja wenn ich das damit
verbringen irgendwie den super perfekten
partner zu finden den ich vielleicht nie
finde sogar sehr wahrscheinlich nicht
oder will ich in wien eine
funktionierende stabile beziehungen die
mich auch in manchen momenten nicht
glücklich macht natürlich gibt es diese
momente aber wo das glück überwiegt und
ich kann mich anderen dingen sind wenden
zum beispiel bücher schreiben oder mache
deshalb im leben natürlich oder in der
partnerschaft auch schwierig wenn man so
kommt und sagt schatz du bist eine
komplexe lieber möchte man ja wirklich
schick der mann war aus als ich diese
schöne begriffen sich sagen die
komplexität reduzieren die fiktion das
gut aber interessant schien die wirklich
jetzt auch annehmen dass sie sagen zum
thema live davon den eindruck hat es
liegt ja auch an ihnen als partner
partnerinnen und man bereit ist
sozusagen hingegen über die person zu
sehen die dieses von andy gefühl einem
geben kann und dazu muss man sich selber
da auch rein geben man könnte man auch
sagen reinsteigern vielleicht das heißt
es ist eben nicht nur der zufall von
außen sondern ich habe auch die
verantwortung und wenn man dann sagt die
haben uns getrennt es hat einfach nicht
gepasst oder es hat nicht sein sollen
dann geht man die verantwortung ja auch
wieder ab da sind wir wieder bei der
frage wie viel freiheit kann ich mir
eigentlich zu nutzen wie sehr bin ich
wirklich meines eigenen glückes schmied
ich habe ich kann mich nicht rein
steigern
in dem fall den sie beschreiben weil
dann versuche ich mir ein zwang
aufzuerlegen es wird alles sehr kampf
ich ich muss eigentlich genau das machen
was wir jetzt bei suppe die ja schon
häufiger besprochen habe ich muss
eigentlich mich eher zurücklehnen glaube
ich mich öffnen dafür dass da was
entstehen kann also eine gewisse
entspannung und offenheit und nicht
konzentriere mich darauf dass jetzt
perfekt wird lassen sie uns bei dieser
offenheit noch ein bisschen bleiben nie
fiel noch ein zitat ein vom twitter
gründer jack dorsey der hat gesagt
erwarten sie das unerwartete auch wieder
dialektisch funktioniert eigentlich
überhaupt nicht ein widerspruch in sich
aber das meint wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen dieses sehr in dem moment oder
dass wir uns zurücklehnen wie sie gesagt
haben uns mal schauen was da auf uns
zukommt ist dass die haltung von der sie
generell sagen würden das ist die
angemessene lebenshaltung wenn wir zum
fall zulassen wollen gleichzeitig aber
doch auch noch ein bisschen selber
bestimmen wollen
ja ich meine letzten endes als wenn man
das so sagen
seien sie offen erwarten erwarten sie
das unerwartete also ich bin ja keine
ich bin ja keine kein schwamm also ich
bin ja nicht einfach nur so ein passives
ding was jetzt mal so alles aufnimmt was
da so kommen mag an unerwarteten sondern
ich mache damit was ich wähle aus ich
gucke was lasse ich rein was ich nicht
rein also soweit ich das in irgendeiner
form kann aber ich glaube schon dass
erst mal so eine grundhaltung der
offenheit dass das dass das etwas ist
was einen wirklich auch lebendig hält
also was das ist eigentlich der motor
der lebendigkeit und ich finde es gibt
bestimmte lebensumstände übrigens auch
beruflich die sind und das ist glaube
ich der einzige spur den ich mir selber
mal gegeben habe dass ich mich aus
lebens kontexten die meine lebendigkeit
töten als ich mich aus denen wirklich
raus begebe und das passiert das
passiert nämlich genau dann wenn kein
raum ist für kreativität denn wenn es zu
bürokratisch wird wenn es zu eng wird
wenn wenn man das gefühl hat man kann
nicht mehr frei denken oder nicht mehr
frei atmen und das kann in der liebe
natürlich genauso sein und ich glaube in
dem moment wenn man wirklich merkt die
lebendigkeit die stirbt dann muss man
auch was ändern
also es gibt ja eigentlich so zwei
prinzipien die evolution und die
revolution man kann sagen evolution
meint okay wir haben irgendwie ein
problem aber wir arbeiten an uns und wir
gucken mal entwickelt sich und so oder
die revolution dass man sagt weg alles
weg noch mal ganz neu ich deshalb so
geht's nicht so geht's nicht und ich
glaube dass man diesen moment für sich
spüren muss dass die sitzung ist eine
schöne forschung von jennifer müller von
der wharton school in pennsylvania die
buch geschrieben hat über den bikes
games creative city also die neigung
gegen kreativität wie die entsteht und
sie beschreibt das eher nachvollziehbar
dass unsicherheit eigentlich der
voraussetzung dafür ist dass die neigung
zu kreativität zurück geht und dass auch
die fähigkeit zurückgeht gute neue
innovative ideen zu erkennen und das
finde ich ganz interessant im anschluss
an das was sie gerade gesagt haben man
muss sich schon selber permanent wieder
auf den prüfstand stellen und fragen bin
ich eigentlich so in mustern und in
ängsten und in standards gefangen dass
ich gar nicht mehr in der lage bin das
zu sehen was ja auch viele große
unternehmen als problem haben was die
politik als problem hat an vielen
stellen was jeder einzelne der ängstlich
in schubladen unterwegs als ein problem
hat und man muss sich da öffnen und wenn
wir es gesellschaftlich anschaut glaube
ich haben wir im moment die situation wo
die unsicherheit wächst ja durch die
ganzen globalen veränderungen die wir
haben handelskriege andere rolle der usa
und so weiter und sofort wächst alles
was da bevorsteht und menschen werden
dann ängstlicher bei mehr unsicherheit
da ist und verschließen sich und in der
regel sind solche zeit nicht die zeiten
in denen innovationen eben blühen
das ist ein zusammenhang der glaube ich
in der in der politischen betrachtung
der gesellschaftlichen betrachtung
wichtig ist eine große sicherheit eine
große freiheit führt dazu dass auch der
in die innovationskraft einer
gesellschaft eine wirtschaft auch sehr
viel größer sein kann als unter
restriktiven bedingungen
sie beide haben aber auch darüber
nachgedacht dass gerade unter den
gegenwärtigen bedingungen aber auch in
unserer zeit die arbeit einen so
wichtigen bestandteil unserer existenz
ausmacht sie haben ein buch geschrieben
mit dem titel die genuss arbeiter da
geht es genau darum dass wir ja auch
noch ach so gerne arbeiten und darin
auch in einer
dauer ausbeutung schlaufe bauern betonen
wie toll die arbeit ist und sie haben
ein sehr eindrückliches buch geschrieben
über ein burnout den sie vor einiger
zeit hatten und dieses gefühl dass man
eigentlich so begeistert ist von dem was
man tut das trägt ja vielleicht auch
dazu bei dass man in so eine
erschöpfungs situation oder eine
situation rein kommt in jemand nicht
mehr kreativ sein kann also ich frage
mich anders gesagt woher kommt denn
sozusagen das gefühl der revolution wenn
unsere welt eigentlich so gemacht ist
das immer noch luft nach oben ist es
geht ja immer noch weiter evolution ist
immer möglich
ja also ich glaube was was was diesen
diesen arbeits kontext angeht und dass
man da eben tatsächlich nicht diese wir
haben ja ein ganz darüber gesprochen
diese gelassenheit hat mal loszulassen
habe das buch gelesen brief an mein
leben von ihnen ganz ganz tolles buch
also für mich auch wirklich wichtig
aber das wusste ich noch gar nicht
jedenfalls dass das ist natürlich ein
problem auch ein gesellschaftliches
problem das uns sozusagen dieses dieses
loslassen und locker lassen und raum für
spiel lassen so in dieser weise gar
nicht zugestanden wird eben weil von uns
erwartet wird sei produktiv aber hab
auch noch spaß dran also und spaß aber
auch nur so lange wie du produktiv bist
und das spielen heißt ja eben auch dass
man dinge tut die erstmal zu nichts
führen vielleicht auch dass man objektiv
betrachtet vielleicht auch zeit
verschwendet oder subjektiv betrachtet
man es kommt nix man es geht nix man
geht nur spazieren usw
das meint ja kreativität auch also
eigentlich sind ja die momente wo etwas
kreativ gesehen glückt das sind ja die
wenigeren momente die die weitaus
größeren moment und das sagt ja jeder
schriftsteller und jede schriftstellerin
sind ja diese diese zeiten in denen man
in denen da nix ist in denen man
irgendwie gucken muss bis die
inspiration wiederkommt und dann glaube
ich ich glaube aber dass es zu leicht
während sagen das ist immer nur die
gesellschaft und das so und der
neoliberalismus und so weiter sondern
das sind natürlich immer auch dinge in
mir selber die mich dazu prädestinieren
oder aus denen ich vielleicht auch so
einen sekundären lust gewinns hier warum
ich in diese schlaufen komme warum ich
mir selber die luft abdrücken so und und
das ist glaube ich in meinem buch ist
ein entscheidender punkt ich glaube auch
in ihrem buch gewesen dass man sich
selber auch befragt also dieses erkenne
sich selbst dass man wirklich guckt was
sind denn meine eigenen motivation in
dieses schlaufe zu kommen und somit auch
wieder im handlungsmacht zurückzukriegen
weil ich finde immer dieses die
gesellschaft ist schuld das bringt einen
auch in seine ohnmacht jungen haben sie
eine antwort was ich die eigene
motivation in diese schlaufe zu kommen
ja ich also sagen wir mal ich finde es
gibt so eine so eine dass der ehrgeiz
der hat ja so eine eigentümliche
dialektik schon im wort also man könnte
jetzt ganz viel dazu sagen ich könnte
jetzt auch ganz viel persönliches
erzählen dazu reicht die zeit aber nicht
aber hermann aber ein punkt vielleicht
nur auch aus diesem buch ist dass ich
mir diesen begriff des ehrgeizes genauer
ansehen also weil ich glaube schon ich
würde mich schon als einen ehrgeizigen
menschen beschreiben der wirklich große
lust daran hat dinge wirklich gut zu
machen und und perfekt zu machen und so
weiter und das bringt einen natürlich
auch in diese schlafe aber wenn es nur
das wäre glaube ich dann könnte man
tatsächlich auch noch vielleicht auch
mal loslassen weil man merkt ich kann
das jetzt nur besonders gut machen weil
wenn ich loslassen kann aber im ärgert
steckt noch was anderes und das ist was
was wirklich ekliges eigentlich das ist
nämlich die gier nach ehre und da geht
es um anerkennung und und diese diese
und natürlich würde man auch sagen ja
anerkennung ist doch auch wichtig ja
also kampf um anerkennung berühmtes buch
von axel honneth oder nehmen wie hegel
also die nur die anerkennung zweier
selbstbewusstsein geführt überhaupt dazu
dass wir uns als selbstbewusst seine
verstehen können aber anerkennung kann
eben auch was porto pathologisches
kriegen und ich glaube dass sozusagen
und jetzt komme ich wieder auf einen
gesellschaftlichen aspekt natürlich auch
zurück unsere gesellschaft begünstigt
auch so eine gewisse
gier nach anerkennung ist natürlich viel
mit medien zu tun mit der selbst ja ein
medien aus den ich übrigens jetzt
ausgestiegen bin weil ich das wirklich
nicht mehr mitmachen will diese art der
kommunikation
aber ich eben und insofern glaube ich
muss man die eigenen antriebe wirklich
sehr genau hinterfragen
ich glaube es gibt auch sie haben das
ganz am anfang unserer unseres gesprächs
gesagt es gibt auch einen lebenszyklus
der persönlichen sehr entität und am
anfang steckt man natürlich sehr viel
mehr in den schubladen der erwartet die
erwartungen anderer in die man sich
irgendein sortieren muss um zum beispiel
eine karriere zu machen oder irgendwo
sich weiterentwickeln zu können ist auch
sehr viel unsicherer stichwort
unsicherheit und kreativität
zusammenhang und mein gefühl ist da habe
ich auch ein paar jahrzehnte gebraucht
dass es wenn man älter wird tatsächlich
anders wird und dass die die ruhe die
einkehrt auch das nicht mehr erwartungen
entsprechen müssen nicht mehr irgendwo
hin müssen sich mehr zurückgehen können
sich mehr öffnen können zudem was was
kommt dazu führt das dann wirklich der
holz und auch wieder ein ganz anderer
ist für den dass das finden das nicht
gesucht und wir haben viele auch darüber
gesprochen was kann gesellschaftlich
geschehen um centipede zu ermöglichen um
wieder das spielerische vielleicht
reinzubringen
und dazu gehört für mich auch ein
bisschen das stichwort lob des
scheiterns im silicon valley ist das
sehr ihn geworden jetzt ausgehend von
mexiko diese faqs zu organisieren gibt
es auch in europa gibt es auch in der
schweiz wo leute lustvoll ihr scheitern
erzählen es gibt auch die fällt also die
felder conference die konferenz des
scheiterns und er leute erzählen da wie
sie auf die nase gefallen sind ist das
jetzt eine gute idee um sozusagen zu
zeigen man kann sich irren sehr ntpc
braucht erstmal den umweg oder den
ableger oder ist das schon wieder der
versuch sozusagen gewollt
das scheitern lernen zu wollen um den zu
fahren dann doch wieder aus zuschauen
etwas visieren das finde ich wir können
das scheitern auch frisieren muss ich
sagen dass mir übrigens jetzt während
wir uns hier so angeregt unterhalten
einfällt ist das eigentlich diese
gesprächssituation ein schönes beispiel
für serien die pid ist nämlich dass sie
als moderator in einem rahmen schaffen
in dem wir uns unterhalten können aber
uns durch ihre wunderbare art der
moderation raum lassen raum lassen damit
sich was ereignen kann also eigentlich
ist es genau das was er in die paket
doch meinte es ist auch nicht ausgewählt
habe und keinen zufall haben er werde
jetzt hier denn sie uns jetzt genau so
wird sozusagen jedes jeden millimeter
vorgeben würden und quasi uns abfragen
würden würde sich nichts ereignet also
vielleicht noch einmal zu in verkappte
ich bin da auch der meinung es ist
inzwischen ein bisschen kult wenn das
hilft kann man es machen aber ich glaube
der große erfinder der über 2000 patente
angemeldet hat unter anderem die die
glühlampe und so weiter der hat mal
gesagt scheitern ist für mich lernen und
ich glaube der aspekt wäre der
wichtigere es geht um das scheitern per
se und es geht darum dass man zwischen
schritte des nicht erfolgs zu lassen
muss um irgendwann einen erfolg zu haben
und das könnte auch für die
gesellschaftliche entwicklung von serien
tippe die sich ja nicht eine hilfreiche
herangehensweise seien zum beispiel
indem man nicht forschungsanträge
einreichen muss bei denen eigentlich
schon klar ist wie das ergebnis ist
damit dann legitimiert werden kann dass
öffentliche gelder für dieses ergebnis
sozusagen zur verfügung gestellt worden
sind in dem man auch bestimmte
öffentliche prüfungsprozesse durch
rechnungshöfe so macht das nicht nur
einen positiv erfolgreich
abgeschlossenes projekt legitim ihr bar
ist weil das das führt genau dazu dass
man spd und den erfolg durch zufall
überall ausschließt und wenn wir uns
darauf konzentrieren dass das lernen im
prozess des scheiterns der eigentlich
wichtiger aspekt dass ich glaube dann
könnte das enorm viel gutes bewirken
das ist ein wunderbares schlusswort und
der zufall will es dass wir am ende
ich ende wieder mal mit einer postkarte
die ich erhalten habe ich habe einen
wunderbaren postkarten von wittgenstein
und tat seltsamer zufall dass alle die
menschen deren schädel man geöffnet hat
ein gehirn hatten und ich habe mir
gedacht zufall oder nicht ich bin froh
dass es so ist sonst könnten wir nicht
philosophieren hören sei dank vielen
dank dass sie bei uns zu gast
danke sehr nächste woche ist laura ließ
wird bei uns zu gast ist
generalsekretärin des council of the
world leaders ist auch in kontakt mit
den mächtigsten frauen der welt ist
macht männlich und was heißt wahre
gleichstellung
ich bat findet's raus am kommenden
sonntag ausnahmsweise allerdings erst um
12 statt um 11 uhr und jetzt gleich
gehts weiter mit fhm cichon dem
wunderbaren israelischen autor der sein
schicksal als holocaust-überlebende
positiv zu wenden wusste skivergnügen
damit und eine gute woche
[Musik]